ce soir j'ai regardé la télévision pour
vous ah ouais ça ou alors c'est bernard
montiel n'a plus d'amis non sérieux
c'est tout oui oui lundi non j'ai vu un
film qu'on a tourné un court-métrage et
sinon vous allez vous la péter comme ça
toutes les missions et d'éblouir un peu
ya pas une soirée la nouvelle va nous
raconter où il y avait des gens connus
et tous à badiner avec valérie
trierweiler vendredi soir c'est inédit
c'est vrai oui les fans de hollande
c'est que tu es drôle c'est que toute la
presse disait qu'elle était déjà parti à
londres et en fait on a dîné ensemble en
bout d'histoire
bon c'était l'anniversaire de saïda
jawad l'ex compagne de gérard jugnot
donc c'est une très très sympa donc
c'était une grosse fête elle a dansé
jusqu'à 5 heures du mat nan c'est pas
vrai a récemment à wemmel à pécho pas
été super elle a essayé mais halak s'est
dit ah ouais ben oui mais elle fait peur
si à chaque fois que vous la choper
salive derrière
[Applaudissements]